chers amis depuis des mois on nous avait
prédit le pire est aujourd'hui grâce à
nicolas nous avons le meilleur nous vous
avons tous ici rassembler notre famille
politique elle est pacifiée elle est
rassemblé et les remobiliser
ne nous trompons pas aujourd'hui est un
grand jour c'est celui de la reconquête
de la droite et du centre
et pour moi qui comme pour beaucoup
d'entre vous vient de la famille
gaulliste je pense à un homme celui qui
de 1976 à 2007 nous inspirer nous a
guidés nous a rassemblé aussi en créant
l'ump en eux en unissant pour la
première fois les trois composantes de
la droite française
les gaullistes les libéraux les
démocrates chrétiens
celui à qui je pense c'est celui pour
qui nous avons tant d'admiration et tant
d'affection
celui dont des centaines de fois nous
avons scandé le nom c'est à jacques
chirac que je pense
je n'oublie pas non plus ceux qui ont
présidé l'ump alain juppé jean françois
copé et bien sûr nicolas et avec nicolas
aujourd'hui c'est une nouvelle page qui
s'écrit
c'est la page des républicains ce beau
non ce nom qui sonne juste
ce nom qui sonne fort ce nom qui nous
unit ce nom qui nous transcende même et
c'est justement la force que nicolas
vient nous proposer
c'est de nous transcender de penser à
l'avenir de la france que nous voulons
la france que nous voulons c'est celle
que méticuleusement françois hollande
avim
ils abîment sur le plan économique ils
la vivent sur le plan budgétaire
ils abîment sur le plan social il abîme
en franchissant un pas de plus vers un
modèle anti travail comme les
socialistes l'ont toujours fait souvenez
vous souvenez vous de 80 la retraite à
60 ans souvenez-vous de 88 le et rémy
souvenez-vous de 97 des 35 heures et de
la cmu avec hollande aujourd'hui c'est
l'explosion de l'aide médicale pour les
clandestins
c'est la création des remy jeunes qui ne
donne pas son nom est pour moi qui ai
commencé à travailler à 17 ans pour tous
ceux qui croient à la valeur travail à
l'effort au mérite c'est insupportable
quelle société
préparons nous pour nos enfants une
france d'assister
si nous continuons avec les socialistes
aujourd'hui pourtant il y a un remède
absolu plus de travail plus de liberté
d'entreprendre moins de charges et moins
d'impôts
il nous faudra pour cela du courage le
courage de faire ce que nous promettons
depuis des années sans aller toujours au
bout de nos convictions en finir
définitivement avec les 35 heures
baisser le coût du travail ce qui
signifie réformer les retraites réformé
la sécurité sociale arrêter de faire
porter l'effort fils l'effort fiscal
sur les classes moyennes qui n'en
peuvent plus en finir avec le collège
unique qui est le premier vecteur du
chômage des jeunes et imposer
l'apprentissage à 14 ans oui il nous
faudra un courage infini pour rompre
avec cette france socialiste
bureaucratique fiscaliste égalitariste
oui la france a été abîmée par le
président hollande profondément abîmée
parce qu'il l'a profondément divisé hier
ils imposaient la loi taubira
aujourd'hui encore ils manipulent il
endort l'opinion publique en préparant
la légalisation de fête de la gpa actant
ainsi la marchandisation du corps des
femmes et il y aurait encore tant à dire
sur les lois de déresponsabilisation
pénale de madame taubira sur les salles
de shoot de madame touraine sur les
quotas de migrants que monsieur 15,9 est
en train de négocier pour les français
aujourd'hui c'est l'overdose
c'est l'écoeurement face à une société
où on défend d'abord le délinquant
l'assisté le fraudeur et en même temps
des volets la famille
mes amis le temps de la révolte est
venue celle des français digne droit
travailleurs qui veulent une france
meilleure pour eux et pour leurs enfants
c'est la mission des républicains c'est
votre mission
c'est notre mission c'est la mission de
nicolas et je lui dis dès aujourd'hui
qui est dès demain nicolas les députés
républicains seront avec toi derrière
toi pour porter ce projet pour la france